.
Ein Auto mit Düsenantrieb.
Ein Umhang,
der Kamikaze-Sprünge abfängt.
Und Enterhaken, die locker
aus dem Handgelenk gefeuert werden.
Was Batmans Ausrüstung
im echten Leben draufhaben müsste,
das checken wir jetzt.
Guten Tag zusammen.
Check for 4.
Eines der Themen,
die ihr euch am häufigsten wünscht,
ist ... na, na, na, na, Batman.
Pünktlich zum Film reden wir daher
über Batmans Autos und Gadgets.
Ich kann das kaum erwarten.
Aufregend.
Ich bespreche solche Themen
nicht allein,
sondern mit dem Physiker Henry.
Hey, Jack.
Der Beruf Batman
ist schon über 80 Jahre alt.
Weil der Typ unter der Maske
super reich ist,
und eine fancy Tech-Firma hat,
haben sich im Laufe der Jahre
viele Gadgets angesammelt.
Darunter auch ein Hai-Abwehr-Spray.
Shark-Abwehr-Spray!
Das wäre klasse,
wenn ein Sharknado kommt.
Ja, aber das ist ja völlig gaga.
Das ist dem Humor
der 60er-TV-Serie geschuldet.
Das war übertrieben.
Der neue Batman
ist viel düsterer.
Willst du Gerechtigkeit?
Ich will Vergeltung.
Es gibt etwas, das zu jeder
Batman-Version dazugehört.
Nämlich ...
... das Bat-Mobil.
*Musik*
Weil es so viele Versionen gibt,
brauchen wir einen Überblick.
Wir haben die Film-Gorillas gebeten,
eine Batmobilgeschichte zu schreiben.
Das macht Daniel für uns.
Hey Jack, hey Henry.
Das Batmobil hat einen langen Weg
hinter sich.
Es ist so alt
wie die Fledermaus selbst.
1939 wurde es als reguläres Auto
inszeniert.
Es war die Privatkarre
von Bruce Wayne.
Erst in den neuen Comic- und
Fernsehreichen wurde es verändert.
Damit wurden dann auch
Verbrecher bekämpft.
Sein Markenzeichen
war ein Düsenantrieb.
In den 60er Jahren war es eher
eine Art Popart-Sportwagen.
Er war ungelenk und plump.
Ende der 80er-Jahre war es dann
ein angsteinflößendes Geschoss.
Seitdem haben sich die Dinge
immer wieder verändert.
Später konnte sich das Mobil
ruckzuck in ein Motorrad verwandeln.
Im neuen Trailer warfen wir schon
einen Blick auf das neue Modell.
Es ist ein bisschen retro,
ein bisschen Protzkarre.
Ein wenig Panzer
wie die letzten Fahrzeuge.
Ich bin gespannt.
Danke, Daniel.
Was ist den Lieblings-Modell?
Das von Michael Keaton
mit der Turbine.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Was ist euer Lieblingsmobil?
Schreibt mir das in die Kommentare.
Wenn wir den Real-live-check machen,
müssen wir festhalten,
dass es schon echte Batmobile gibt.
Es gibt so krasse Fans, die
die Dinger fahrtüchtig nachbauen.
Der Kollege hat das Modell
von "Down of Justice" nachgebaut.
Aus Glas- und Karbonfasern
mit 700 PS.
Das spuckt sogar Flammen.
Das darf man nur in Dubai fahren.
Wo denn sonst.
Bei solchen Modellen
zählt v.a. das Design.
Aber beim echten Batmobil
gibt es spezielle Technik.
Das hat zum Verbrennungsmotor
noch ein Jet-Triebwerk eingebaut.
Also einen Düsenangrieb.
Auch Robert Pattinsons Mobil hat das.
Wie funktioniert das, Henry?
Ein Düsentriebwerk
basiert auf dem 3. Newtoschen Axiom:
Wenn 2 Körper Kräfte aufeinander
ausüben, sind diese gleich groß.
Aber sie sind
entgegengesetzt gerichtet.
Die Masse
wird nach hinten beschleunigt,
und sie wirkt genau so
auf das Triebwerk nach vorn.
Welche Massen das sind,
ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Bei Flugzeugtriebwerken
hat man im Kern eine Verbrennung.
Die treibt den Fan an,
der Außenluft ansaugt.
Die wird nach hinten beschleunigt
und schiebt das Flugzeug nach vorn.
Bei Militärflugzeugen
ist das im Prinzip genauso.
Hier wird weniger Luft angesaugt.
Da wird stärker verbrannt.
Da geben die Abgase den Schub.
Bei Raketen geben die Abgase
komplett den Antriebsschub.
Denn im Weltall
kann man keine Luft ansaugen.
Alle basieren also darauf,
Zeug nach hinten wegzuschmeißen.
Das wird im Film
durch die Flammen gezeigt.
Bei Tim Burton lodern die noch
locker vor sich hin.
In jüngeren Versionen gibt es
einen gerichteten Feuerstrahl.
Für welche Art von Triebwerk
spricht das?
Für den kurzen Schub muss
das Triebwerk nicht effizient sein.
In kurzer Zeit wird viel Treibstoff
hinten raus geballert.
Hier könnte Bruce Wayne die Turbine
eines Militär-Jets einbauen.
Dafür spricht die kompakte Größe.
Die Turbine eines
Passagier-Flugzeuges
würde nicht passen.
Wie funktioniert diese Düse?
Luft wird vorn angesaugt
und komprimiert.
In der Brennkammer
kommt der Treibstoff dazu.
Das Luft- Treibstoff-Gemisch
wird entzündet.
Die entstehenden Abgase
expandieren.
Sie werden durch die Form der
Turbine nach hinten beschleunigt.
In manchen Antrieben
gibt es einen Nachbrenner.
Auf Knopfdruck wird Treibstoff
in den heißen Abgasstrahl
reingeschossen.
Das ergibt einen Extraschub.
Fährt das Batmobil mit Düsenantrieb?
Macht es auf Knopfdruck
diesen Nachbrenner an?
Oder hat es
einen normalen Verbrennungsmotor?
Und die Düse wird per Knopfdruck
eingeschaltet?
Diskutiert das doch
in den Kommentaren.
Fakt ist: Knopfdruck und Extraschub
sehen wir den definitiv.
Beim Batman Beginn beim "Tumbler".
Da wird es
von Batmans Chefingenieur erwähnt.
*Sie sprechen Englisch.*
*Knall*
Das ist sinnvoll für Bruce Wayne.
Er muss ja manchmal
über Hochhaus-Dächer.
*Sie sprechen Englisch.*
Das ist sogar fast realistisch.
Er kann nicht zwischen
2 gleich hohen Häusern springen.
Schwerkraft zieht ihn
während des Sprunges nach unten.
Da kann er Schub gebrauchen.
Das reicht aber nicht.
Wirkt die Schubkraft nur horizontal
hilft sie nicht gegen Schwerkraft.
Er muss schräg abspringen.
Dass die Schubkraft
schräg nach oben wirkt.
Er müsste einen Hoch-Start machen.
Das gibt es tlw. bei Show-Rennen,
hier ist Batman realistisch.
Der Tumbler aus der
"Dark Knight"-Trilogie,
hatte nur Propangas-Tanks.
Aber konnte Sprünge
von bis zu 10 m machen.
Sehr ungewöhnlich,
denn sie werden für die Optik gebaut.
Regisseur Christopher Nolan
wollte es anders.
Er wollte eine handfeste
Manifestation des "Batmobils".
Beim 1. Sprung
ging das Auto kaputt
und musste repariert werden.
Bei dem Aufprall
wirken sehr große Kräfte.
Es bräuchte eine Federung.
So ein Sprung
ist ein Unfall mit Ansage.
Wie eine
"Science vs. Fiktion"-Episode.
Also Autos mit Düsenantrieb
gibt es in echt.
Die werden für
Geschwindigkeitsrekorde gebaut.
Sie werden bei uns
Raketenautos genannt.
Obwohl auch Autos dabei sind,
die nicht nur
reine Raketenantriebe nutzen.
Sondern auch solche,
die die Luft ansaugen.
Aber sie sehen Raketen
ziemlich ähnlich.
Im Gegensatz zum "Batmobil".
Das ist der momentane
Weltrekord-Halter.
Das Fahrzeug
durchbrach 1997 die Schallmauer.
Es kam auf eine Geschwindigkeit
von 1.228 km/h.
Dieser Rekord
ist bislang ungebrochen.
Es gab mehrere Versuche,
darüber zu kommen.
Heißester Kandidat dafür
war bislang
das britische Überschallfahrzeug
"Bloodhound LSA".
Das würde gerne
auf 1.600 km/h kommen.
Da sieht es aber
schlecht mit der Finanzierung aus.
Bei so hohen Geschwindigkeiten
sind Bremsen ein Problem.
Deswegen haben diese Autos
neben den Scheibenbremsen
auch Bremsfallschirme eingebaut.
Die gab es schon beim "Batmobil".
Man muss mit solchen Fahrzeugen
nicht unbedingt
Geschwindigkeitsrekorde aufstellen.
Das stell ich mir
auf der Autobahn nett vor.
Mit Düsenantrieb zu fahren.
Irgendwie
hat keiner so ein Düsenauto.
In den 60er Jahren
gab es mal eine Testreihe
mit so einem Auto.
Dem "Turbine Car".
Das sah
wie ein normales Auto aus,
hatte aber Düsenantrieb.
200 Leute haben das getestet,
es hat ihnen gefallen.
Es hat sich nicht durchgesetzt.
Weil es einen hohen
Spritverbrauch hatte.
Auf der Autobahn 13 l/100 km.
Genauso viel
hat es im Stand verbraucht.
Im Stadtverkehr
hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
I don't care.
Autos mit Düsenantrieb sind weder
besonders umweltfreundlich,
noch besonders
portemonnaiefreundlich.
Aber Bruce Wayne ist Milliardär.
Der kann sich das leisten.
Batman würde bei einer
Verfolgungsjagd
nicht an einer roten Ampel halten.
Die 2. ikonische Batman-Ausrüstung
ist definitiv sein Anzug.
Aber da ich auf keinen Fall
über die Nippel
von George Clooney reden möchte,
konzentrieren wir uns mal
auf seinen Umhang.
Da müssen uns
die Film-Gorillas normal helfen.
Daniel, was kann der ganz genau?
Der Umhang
hat eine optische Funktion.
Er lässt Batman
wie eine Fledermaus aussehen.
Er hat mehrere Varianten
und Funktionen.
Er schützt ihn z.B. vor Kugeln.
Er ist cool,
wenn er ihn fliegen lässt.
Das Cape besteht
aus einem besonderen Material.
Er sieht aus wir normaler Stoff,
kann aber zum Gleitschirm werden.
Danke Daniel!
Wenn dieser Umhang
ein Wing Suite wäre,
wäre er ja damit schneller.
Genau.
Die schaffen
über 100 km/h horizontal
und um die 50 km/h nach unten.
Der Rekord für die Geschwindigkeit
nach vorne liegt bei über 300 km/h.
Batman fliegt nicht so schnell,
aber sein Umhang ist größer.
Er geht in Richtung Paragliding.
Da sinkt man etwas gemütlicher.
Dass die Größe des Umhangs
eine Rolle spielt,
errechneten Studenten.
Sie errechneten, dass der Umhang
mit 4 m Spannweite nicht ausreicht,
dass Batman sicher landen kann.
Er würde abstürzen und zermatschen.
Damit das nicht passiert,
müsste der Umhang so groß sein,
wie ein Paraglide-Schirm.
Wir halten fest:
die Größe haut nicht hin.
Aber Christopher Nolan
absolviert Stunts mit dem Umhang.
Z.B. als er nach Hong Kong reist.
Da geht er auf einen Wolkenkratzer.
Er macht einen heftigen Sprung
nach unten und gleitet entspannt.
Wäre das möglich?
Da müssen wir alle ganz stark sein.
Batman ist nicht stark genug,
um so durch Hong Kong zu gleiten.
Aber wie kann Batman
für irgendwas nicht stark genug sein?
Es gibt den kritischen Moment,
wenn er die Flügel ausbreitet,
da wirken sehr starke Kräfte.
Hier steht er auf dem Hochhaus,
es ist 416 m hoch.
Als der Film gedreht wurde, war es
das höchste Gebäude Hong Kongs,
Jetzt ist es das zweithöchste.
Er springt dann runter
und ist 4 sec. im freien Fall.
Er wird auf 40 m/sec. beschleuningt.
Das sind 140 km/h.
Den Luftwiderstand
können wir vernachlässigen,
denn die Zeit ist kurz.
Und Batman bietet der Luft
wenig Angriffsfläche.
Dann spannt Batman seine Flügel auf.
Damit spielt der Luftwiderstand
eine riesen Rolle.
Denn nun bremst
ihn die riesen Fläche.
Das zwingt ihn,
so eine Kurve zu fliegen.
Hier wirkt die Zentripetalkraft.
Die ist Masse
mal Geschwindigkeit im Quadrat
geteilt durch den Kreisbahn-Radius.
Über die Zentripetalkraft
sprachen wir beide schon mal.
Mit der Formel können wir errechnen,
welche Kräfte auf Batman wirken.
Genau.
Das ist die Kraft, die er braucht,
um die Flügel zu halten.
Sonst würden seine Arme und Flügel
einfach nach oben wegklappen.
Lass uns
mit dem Kreisbahnradius anfangen.
Den können wir grob abschätzen:
20 m.
Jetzt brauchen wir
noch die Geschwindigkeit.
Da setzen wir 40 m/sec. ein.
Wir brauchen noch Batmans Masse.
Die nehmen wir
aus dieser "offiziellen" Tabelle.
Da stehen 82 kg drin.
Dazu kommt noch die Ausrüstung dazu,
also sagen wir 100 kg.
Das setzen wir jetzt ein.
Wir kommen auf eine Kraft
von ca. 8.000 Newton.
Das ist so als würde Batman
in jeder Hand 400 kg halten
Holy shit!
Zum Vergleich: beim Gewichtheben
stemmen Menschen 200 kg.
Aber mit beiden Armen.
Keine Chance für Batman.
Der Umhang sieht geil aus,
aber in Sachen Funktionalität
könnte nachgelegt werden.
Er müsste größer sein,
für ein sicheres Gleiten und Landen.
Er bräuchte eine stabile
Konstruktionsweise,
um Batmans Arme
beim Fliegen nicht kaputt zu machen.
Korrekt.
*Batman-Titelmusik*
Es gibt eine Maßeinheit,
die Batman heißt.
Sie wurde in Asien verwendet.
1903 wurde festgelegt,
dass 1 Batman 2,97 kg entspricht.
D.h. unser Batman
wiegt ca. 34 Batman.
Das letzte Gadget,
was wir uns heute anschauen wollen,
ist die Grapple Gun,
auch Grapnel Gun genannt.
Daniel, erklär uns doch mal,
was Bruce damit meint.
In den frühen Jahren benutzte Batman
schon Seile und Widerhaken,
um zu klettern.
Die Grapple Gun gibt es erst
seit dem 1. Tim-Burton-Film.
Es ist eine Spezialpistole
mit Seilwinde.
Die benutzt er als Harpune,
um Gegner an sich ran zuziehen.
Oder er nutzt es,
um sich oder andere
vor dem Fall zu retten.
Ein heldenhaftes Tool.
Die Wahrheit ist,
er rettet damit niemanden.
Warum nicht?
Sprechen wir das
an einer Szene durch.
Die aus "The dark Knight".
Joker fällt von einem Haus runter.
Batman schießt hinterher,
fängt Joker ein und
rettet ihn vor dem Absturz.
Das ist normal für Batman.
Was ist das Problem?
In der Szene
wird der Joker abrupt abgebremst.
Je nach Schnelligkeit,
wirkt eine große Kraft auf ihn.
*unverständliches Gemurmel*
Kraft ist Masse mal Beschleunigung.
Bremsen
ist auch eine Beschleunigung.
Es ist
eine Geschwindigkeitsänderung/Zeit.
Um das auszurechnen brauchen wir
die Geschwindigkeit Jokers,
vor seiner Abbremsung.
Er fällt 4 sec.,
wie Batman in Honkong.
Seine Geschwindigkeit ist 40 m/sec.,
bevor er auf 0 abgebremst wird.
Wir nehmen als Zeit für das Bremsen
1/10 sec. an.
Multiplizieren wir das mit 84 kg,
der Masse des Jokers,
ergibt es
eine Kraft von 33.600 Newton.
Es entspricht dem 40-fachen
seines Eigengewichts,
was er dabei spürt.
Dabei reißt es dem Joker
wahrscheinlich das Bein raus.
Selbst wenn das nicht passiert,
wirkt eine Beschleunigung
von 40 g auf ihn.
Das ist viel.
Bei 5-6 g
verliert man das Bewusstsein
und Gefäße können platzen.
D.h. bei Joker
sind Gehirnblutungen garantiert.
Da kann man sagen:
"Ist halt der Joker".
Aber am Ende hält Batman oben fest.
Dieselbe Kraft
wirkt also auch auf ihn.
D.h. entweder er fliegt mit runter
oder es haut ihm
die Grapnel Gun aus der Hand.
Wenn es fest verbunden ist
mit dem Anzug,
könnte es seinen Arm ausreißen.
Ja.
Batman bringt den Move ständig.
Nicht nur für sich,
er rettet damit auch andere Menschen.
Den Personen, die er schützen will,
ginge es also nicht mehr so gut.
Die Grapnel Gun kann nicht nur
Dinge abbremsen.
Batman kann sie auch
wie einen Enterhaken benutzen
und sich daran hochziehen.
Hier gibt es also
keine gefährlichen Beschleunigungen.
Nein, die Beschleunigung
ist entspannt.
Hier ist die Frage,
wie schwer die Grapnel Gun ist
mit Motor, Seil und Akku drin.
Kann Batman das entspannt
in der Hand halten?
Da schauen wir ins echte Leben.
Es gibt Youtuber,
die das nachgebaut haben.
Das sieht klobig aus,
funktioniert aber
auf kürzere Distanzen.
Ein "Brushless Motor"
ist darin verbaut.
Der wird umso schwerer,
je mehr Leistung er bringt.
Wie viel Leistung die Grapnel Gun
von Batman bräuchte,
können wir ausrechnen.
Ja.
Leistung ist Energie pro Zeit.
Seine Lage oder potentielle Energie
ändert sich.
Schauen wir uns die Szene
mit Michael Keaton an.
Da ändert er seine Höhe
um ca. 1 Meter in ca. 1 Sekunde.
Wenn wir das einsetzen,
ergibt sich eine Energie-Änderung
von ca. 981 Joule.
Mit der Zeit von 1 Sekunde
ist das eine Leistung von 981 Watt.
Nehmen wir lieber 1.000
oder 1.500 Watt an,
denn der Motor
ist nicht 100% effizient.
Das klappt total gut.
Elektromotoren mit dieser Leistung
gibt es schon im Format,
das gerade mal ein Kilo wiegt.
Damit kann man es locker
per Hand transportieren.
Und der Akku?
Lithiumionen-Akkus
wie in Handys oder Laptops
leisten
zw. 300 und 1.500 Watt pro kg.
Diese Akkus werden immer besser.
Wenn wir davon ausgehen,
dass Batmans Technik up-to-date ist,
macht das für die 1.500 Watt
ca. 1 kg Gewicht.
D.h. 1 kg für den Motor,
1 kg für den Akku,
ein bisschen Gewicht für das Seil,
ca. 2 kg für 30 m Kletterseil.
Wir sind bei insgesamt 4 kg.
Das ist nicht super wenig,
aber Batman ist super trainiert,
ein starker Typ.
Für seine Grapnel Gun
ist das durchaus machbar.
Henry, danke fürs Durchrechnen.
Immer wieder gern.
Danke an Daniel
von den "Filmgorillas"
fürs Einordnen.
Die Links
packe ich in die Infobox.
Schaut vorbei und sagt
liebe Grüße von uns.
Wenn euch das Video gefällt,
gebt uns euer Bat-Signal
in Form eines Daumens nach oben.
Oder lasst einen Kommentar da,
den lesen wir gerne.
Vergesst nicht, diesen Kanal...
... zu abonnieren.
Und die Glocke...
... zu drücken.
Dann sehen wir uns bald wieder.
mit Dr. Holland-Moritz,
dem tanzenden Physiker.
Tschüss.
Wenn ihr heiß
auf Batman-Themen seid,
schaut vorbei
bei den "Filmgorillas".
Da dreht sich diese Woche
alles um den dunklen Ritter.
(mit hoher Stimme) Wir haben hier
ein Video über den Joker.
Copyright MDR 2022